hey what's up guys my name is Ayana
welcome to another github tutorial so
today we're gonna talk about integrating
a github repository with eclipse okay so
to do that basically what the first
thing you'll need is to go to help and
then install new software and the reason
I'm on Windows by the way is because um
I've already got it all set up on Mac
and in order to demonstrate this I'd
have to you know on set it and do this
I'll do the whole thing over again so I
thought it'd be easy to do it on Windows
so the directory that we're gonna work
with it's called a git so that's what it
looks like so you'll have to hit add
then typing a get and then the URL which
is right over here and again the link to
that will be in the description so II
get basically allows you its plugin for
clips and it allows you to integrate get
with eclipse which is obviously
immensely useful so once you type that
in once you select that website hit
select all and then next and then I've
already got installed but if you don't
keep hitting an axis at the agreement
blah blah blah then it will download and
install and then you'll be prompted to
restart Eclipse and hit yes and then
once you driven start eclipse
you should get to this view okay so this
is a blank new workspace as well haven't
done anything here at all so to set this
up what we'll have to do is basically
import it from Eclipse
sorry import it from github directly so
to do that hit file and then actually
first of all hit window go to show you
and then other and then you'll have this
tab here called get this folder here so
I expand that and it'll be a view here
called git repository so hit that and
hit OK and it'll pop up over here okay
and essentially what we're going to do
is clone a git repository but just in
case you don't see this or if you
already got some what you'll have to do
is probably hit file and then import or
you can actually just right click here
and pet in package Explorer or Navigator
and hit import and then you'll see this
tag folder here called git so you wanna
click on that and then projects from get
if you got the github plug-in it'll just
say github over here as well as this and
that a still a lot easier because then
you can just type in shown I had an
all-fired for you but in case you don't
projects from get right here hit
next hit URI hit next and then what
you'll have to do is copy the URI of
this so it's not this link okay what
you'll have to do over here is come over
here and copy the actual HTTP HTTPS here
so copy clipboard there's a button and
then paste it over here so it's
essentially the same step just got a dot
git extension Lee on the end so once you
paste that in and should automatically
detect all the settings so then you
don't need authentication of course it's
a public repository then hit next yeah
you'll get the remote branches there'll
be one called master which is should be
the only one there so grab that okay so
make sure that that's selected then hit
next and it'll set up a directory before
you can change that to whatever you want
by default I think it'll be in Windows
your username then get and then the name
of the project so tarnish out in this
case grab that hit next and then what
you'll have to do once it detects this
is because the repository does not have
a dot project file you'll have to import
it as a general project make sure that
you do that okay so then hit next and
then when that's done hit finish and as
you can see it's imported here now
that's brilliant and if you go over here
you can go to source you can go to
college or jet log in whatever it's all
there which is great
now the problem you might run it you
might run into in fact you probably will
is if you're trying to bug it you this
will show up so the solution cannot be
launched and there are no recent
launches now the reason this shows up is
because this this project that is
important it's not a Java project it's
just a general project and the clip
doesn't know how to run it okay so we
need a teleporter on it okay and one
thing you might notice as well here is
this git repositories tab and this has
all of your stuff like the working
directory with all the source code as
well as the remote addresses which is
where you'll be able to actually fetch
the latest changes but we'll talk about
that in another episode okay so how do
we set this up as an eclipse project now
to do that the best way to do is the
best the best thing to do was actually
delete it so let's right click on it and
hit delete make sure you don't delete
the project contents do not do that okay
and take note of the location cause
you're gonna need that and finished
gonna copy that if I can I'm not sure if
that's copyable but here okay it's now
it's gone okay now we want to go file
new
Java project make sure you hit Java
project and the default location paste
in that thing luckily it did copy and
then whoops turn on chat and then type
the project name shown our chat as well
okay so hit finish if you get imported
right here and if we go to the source
over here and expand it login dot Java
you'll see that if we run it it will
show up now this don't worry about the
style of it unfortunately when I pushed
it didn't push the UI manager stuff that
we added in episode 3 yet so that's why
it doesn't have a UI manager set up
properly that's why it looks weird but
the point is it works now you can
probably notice here that it's not
connected to github anymore because it
doesn't have that little master thing or
whatever to set that up it's really it's
really simple we just need a right click
on the project name hit team and then
share project under get hit next it
should automatically detect it because
we've already got a job get folder here
so just hit finish you can see it
detects it and then this will appear and
then you'll actually be able to fetch
pretty much anything you want so there's
nothing to fetch everything is up today
ok
and that's how that works so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit the like button and I'll see
you guys next time good bye
[Music]
you